j'y arrive y arriveront sans trottoir
[Musique]
toi et moi
pour toujours
avoue nous épouse
nous les hommes nous demandons beaucoup
nous vous demandons d'être forte
de préparer nos repas d'entretenir le
foyer
et surtout d'être discrète
les garçons et leurs jouets au moins on
sait qu'ils avancent
bienvenue aux membres du projet victory
nous sommes réunis par notre foi en
notre mission nous faisons quoi nous
changeons le monde nous faisons quoi
nous changeons le monde exactement
à ton avis qu'est ce qu'ils font
vraiment là bas
ce qu'ils font vraiment
tout ce qu'ils attendent de nous c'est
qu'on reste ici
[Musique]
où on est à l'abri
tu sais seulement ce que c'est ce projet
victory tu as cherché à savoir et toi
s'il te plaît qu'est ce qui se trame ici
arrête alice
et si on est en danger et you are
éleveurs non tac ça ne fait rien
je suis curieux de savoir où elle veut
en venir
écoute ce que je te dis
[Musique]
sur toute la ligne
nous ne reculerons pas nous sommes à
l'avant-garde
il se comporte comme si j'étais folle
je ne suis pas folle
notre vie notre couple
on pourrait tout perdre
je n'ai pas manqué un seul
je ne peux pas rester ici je ne va plus
[Musique]